what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to some kevin samuels
videos
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel as you guys
know i'm trying to hit 20
000 subscribers that's a big goal for
the channel and each and every one of
you help
while you're at it do not forget to hit
ring that notification
bell that way you're going to be
notified of my daily videos and you
won't miss a single one
okay i've never listened to this before
looks like but i like
fast forward to the party because
there's a disconnect the part where he
like
it says he's going to let someone off
between men and women on this
i'm going to tell you i don't know any
men that understand this
i don't know anyway and the men that
came out
were celebrity kind of guys and i'm like
what what do y'all think y'all are doing
some of these guys think that this y'all
want them to defend that
hello hey how are you i am well how are
you
i have my earphones connected give me
one disconnect okay
hi how are you good and don't and
hold on just a second and for people who
keep uploading my stuff from instagram
to youtube
i'm going to get you struck and take
that don't do that i'll upload my own
stuff go ahead
how old are you hi i'm 22 years old
all right so what's going on with this
bonnet stuff
um personally i just had a conversation
with my guy mom about this because you
know i'm from philly
and i see it a lot and um
she actually sent me this skit with um
modique and i had to comment on it and i
just was like i feel as though me
personally
i'm a hair stylist so your hair has to
be done and how you are presented is how
people are going to portray you or you
know how you present yourself
i do agree with this um and i'm actually
kind of a tomboy
so i'm not even someone who dresses up
like crazy or anything but like
if you dress up your hair and dress up
your outfit
and like present yourself a certain way
even if you're not the cutest like you
can
look a lot like quote-unquote badder
than you actually are
so you just have to be careful with it
and then a lot of a lot of women say
they are looking for you know a certain
man
but aren't doing the things that they
should be as a woman
person
is it all right so are you pro bonnet or
anti-bonded do you care
definitely believe you should not be
wearing bodies so okay
so are you married not married
do you want to be married one day yes do
you have any kids
no kids i'ma ask you one question okay
as a woman who wants to be married do
you want children one day
yes why the tongue ring
why the tongue ring i honestly
didn't think about it when i got it but
i feel like once i get older i would
take it out like
maybe now i'm still i mean i did it
because i was young so like i'm getting
older i know that
you know and honestly like
she looks like she has fake lashes like
that stuff looks very trashy to me like
the fake lashes fake nails
fake i mean and there's a way to do it
where like you can do mascara or
whatever and i don't think that looks
trashy but
i don't know like tongue rings kind of
hard 22
yes how did you get how are you when you
got it
said that one more time how old were you
when you got it
literally i just got it two years ago i
was 20.
okay so why
i tell you please do not judge me okay
i'm not gonna judge you
okay the person i was with um you know
before you know he said he didn't mind
me getting it
and i wasn't going to get it if he you
know just disagreed with it so i just
kind of got it anyway he said it was
fine so
i'm not going to say i did it for him
because it was a 50 50. i wanted to get
it as well but if he had a problem with
it i wasn't going to get it
did you think it was do you think it was
cute sexy
what i thought it was maybe sexy
you do know do you know what men
associated that with though
it can be associated with a lot of
things yes what do you think
most men associated with oh no maybe um
she's fast maybe she does things with
her tongue
of course well i'm gonna i'm gonna be
honest the
first time first time i let's see
the purpose of
tongue rings have you ever looked it up
no i have not but i'm pretty sure it
might be
i'm pretty sure you're your companion
it says what is the purpose of a tongue
ring when used for oral sex a small
metal ball or tongue ring at the tip of
the ring to add pleasure t's or such and
so forth
um some people said the tongue ring was
an honor or gift to the gods but that's
not what we do these days most of the
time it's associated with
uh oral gratification
and that's why i asked you initially if
you want to be married
one day you have to already
be thinking about you're you're
somebody's wife in training
well what kind of men are you attracting
what kind of image are you setting
this is something that there was a time
where i had to learn that with like the
pictures i was putting on my instagram
like
um because i would only take pictures
when i went out
so then that's like the image and the
portrayal
that like you're literally giving to
people so it's something that especially
when you're younger like you don't
think as much about because a lot of
times people are like
um giving you like a sort of like
attention for it so you think it's like
positive but you don't realize like how
negative it really looks
and this isn't like i never got a tongue
ring it's not like that's
necessary so i would just say you know
me being young and me
having to think about it for the future
you know now that i am thinking about it
you know that's something that i will
you know
rethink especially if that's in my
future than me wanting to be married you
know
well you're not really young your
grandma i mean if you go back
my grandmother was married by my
grandmother was married by your age
we keep saying yeah i would say
i would say look i personally i always
say because the
guys that they are older so they're
always calling me young so okay i don't
really date anybody
were you ready would you rate were you
raised with your dad in the household
unfortunately not that's the typical
story no
i was not so if you if your dad was in
the household do you think he would be
all right with that
no then that's your answer that's all
i'm saying is like
women tend to let their daughters do
whatever but as a man i'm telling you
you know unless you're football game i'm
pretty sure
well then take the thing out because you
don't need it that's all i'm saying
you don't need it then bye all right so
yeah
bye-bye so look i understand a lot of
times women do stuff
too he can actually be really nice
when they actually take his advice
because
it's like oh it's fun i'm independent
i've grown
yeah tongue rings ladies tongue rings
men are just thinking oh
she's dtf a tongue ring that means she's
that means she must not know how to use
that thing
um i'm just being honest
and here's another thing when you do one
thing it makes it easier
there's a line of thought that if you're
willing to
pierce your tongue or something like
that you want to do something else too
yeah if i can't tell who you are and
your in your
uh you know
photo what in the heck candy girl lord
of mercy
hopefully you ain't naked i don't know
i make no bones for who this mate lord
oh my gosh that happened to me one time
on instagram
oh it was weird i'm mercy jesus hi
hello thank god i'm actually on your
live wow hello
how are you your camera's that
it's too dark can you turn the camera
around or get to a place where
yeah the light's in front how are you
hey
how old are you i'm 35 um how old are
you
old enough to be running the show um yes
what do you got for me
um no i just wanted to come live with
you because
my girlfriends are here and they are
very opinionated and i
actually i got i i got i got i but i
they can be opinionated but i got a show
i'm talking about bonnets tonight
bonnets
yeah that's what's going on right now
what is a bonnet
guys what are we talking about
let me get up to the times here i'm
really sorry oh my gosh
he's so irritated look at him so
i'm not going
you here with your girl hold on time out
slow down
you got your girlfriends over there and
they're very
you guys have time to get off subject
and i'ma bounce you
what's going on with your friends you
got your friends over here they're
opinionated because of what
well just some previous shows i'm sorry
to like catch you off guard i didn't
know about the whole subject tonight but
like i was just trying to express myself
and tell them you know like how you know
how you rate women
you know you can't be a seven you're
you're they're like you're a six if
you're an eight like
and they're like oh well you know who's
this guy
trying to tell us who we are but we
don't care about you
i'm nobody asking i asked them this what
do their husbands think about them
they ain't married that's who i am
damn they don't have to like i mean he
doesn't have to be married like he's
get your big ass on cam get your big ass
on camera if you want to talk to me
yeah get your big ass on camera if you
want to talk to me come on
oh please don't oh guys oh man
yeah she wanted you hey you wanna you
want to smoke
who who am i to say anything nobody i
don't know
it's women like her to get upset with me
because it's the truth now come in here
and cuss and make a fool of yourself
oh you sexy as a [ __ ] hey
shirley
my big ones shirley how you doing
how are you doing you guys very well i
can't hear you
i'm very well yeah i bet you are
uh you doing well uh-huh how tall are
you doing very well
okay she's doing really well yo
you wanna i don't know why her face just
looks angry
that's me or should i judge you i don't
care what you got to say i look better
than you on my worst day
she gonna get upset with me look see
it's women like that that don't like me
because you are lucky no no
no you look fat i'm not you look fat and
you look old
oh fat no stop it oh my gosh
that's why you don't don't bring a knife
to a gun fight
damn i was just talking about how nice
he was too
how old are you daddy's funny
what you got to say
i'm happy don't i look happy yeah that
woman had drank like 12 coors lights and
smoked a pack of virginia slim tonight
miserable as french toast so i'm sorry
to the lady who just called
your friends are upset because somebody
like you is trying to get a better
outcome than they do
so what they want you to do is stay
stuck over there so they have somebody
to split beer with
see if you level up and get yourself out
of there and go to the gym
they don't have anybody to go in on that
on
case of beer they may actually have to
buy their own beer
and that's not what they want to do
because you notice ain't nobody trying
to buy her big ass no drink
ain't nobody trying to buy her big ass
drinks
damn
i can't stand him who did he think he is
huh yeah
over here talking [ __ ]
why she gonna be a fan after that damn
okay back to the bonnets i'll be nice to
you
oh my god that's horrible i'm going to
hell y'all are horrible man
hello how are you i'm good okay
so my before we do this we got to do
this how old are you
i'm 22. okay go ahead
okay you hear his voice like raised with
like happiness you're not too old
so my whole thing with the bonnets the
only time i've worn a bonnet is
actually going to get my hair done
but i don't agree with wearing it like
out
in public or okay my opinion is i
literally don't care
what other people do but if you wear
stuff that looks like pajamas in public
like i mean i've done it i'm not even
gonna lie to you like i'm kind of a
tomboy
but i don't get mad if guys like aren't
looking at me
if i'm dressed like airports or any
pajamas
is meant to be inside the house now yeah
like i mean i'm with her
but damn i'm not above it guys i'm a
tomboy i'm sorry
if um i mean i do i do like try to look
nice but if i'm just going to the store
or something i do not care
so let me ask you a question why do you
think
or why do you feel like women are
arguing
and saying mind your own business why do
you why are why
because it's what they're used to so
like i feel if you don't have a certain
foundation or you're not raised in a
certain way
and you see somebody doing it and you're
raised around it that's what you're
gonna do
so they saw their mom going to the store
grocery shopping with their bonding ones
so they like and a lot of girls
have never been checked ever especially
if they grew up like super pretty
like okay and if anybody tell me
different
my mom did it so why can't i i i i guess
that makes sense
um because i didn't understand why it
would be so offensive
to see this kind of backlash to where
people are really coming at these folks
um i didn't see a lot of this
10 years ago this is a new thing right
so there's a whole new generation
well that's what i'm trying to see is
what mothers i get
because a lot of women because you know
you got the
baby boomers then you guys i'm in
generation x
but generation x didn't walk around with
bonnets
so the women who come on my show they're
not
they're not teenagers these women are
generally in their mid 20s early 30s
wearing violence so these women were not
they were not teenagers 10 years ago
they were still
late teens early 20s so i don't know
well well i can understand what you're
saying i don't know if this necessarily
were raised around that
i think a lot of these women just don't
want anybody to tell them to do what
to do anywhere yeah yeah that's true too
so but anyway i appreciate your opinion
uh thank you
bonnet see and you can't wear a bonnet
going to get your hair done that's
acceptable that makes sense yeah
all right all right bye-bye bye so i've
never worn a bonnet before
and she made a good point you know yeah
women have always when they were like in
between like going to get their hair
done put on a hat
or bonnet i mean or something but you're
going from one place to another
so when she says you know that's what
they're used to because they saw their
mother
and they were raised that way i don't
know if i agree with that because i
didn't see this
10 years ago and many of the women i see
doing this are fully grown
women to me and i could be wrong but it
just seems like a lot of women today are
just outright
lazy i mean
and it's amazing that many of these
people wearing these bonnets
i've noticed that a lot of girls are
lazy if they just grew up super pretty
and never had to like do anything
because like men would always do
everything because they're
super pretty spend more time getting
their acrylic nails put on
oh my god that's crazy do you know
what's crazy how much money
you think about you get your nails done
every two weeks it's like 200
every two weeks that's 400 a month
some girls right some people pay more
some pay less um
well because i'm assuming they get their
toes done too
time's up by 12. it's like over four
grand a year that's a lot of money
but um hey that's what it's about we got
15 000 folks in here
chocolate jesus uh so
i'll say this too that i really want to
get to
the question about bonnets and the
question is
modern women are you are are you
are you our business hello
hi how are you i'm good how are you
good how old are you i'm 24. all right
so the question is about bonnets or
are modern women are you our business
which one do we want to talk about
um i'll talk about the bonnets all right
go ahead what do you guys think
so i have natural hair and after i get
my hair done
um if it's humid or something and i have
like
an event to go to i will wrap my hair or
put a bond on
just to protect my hair from frizzing up
standing up things like that
while you're in the house or you're in
chains no like if i'm like going to the
actual event
but when you leave your house what's it
what's what's on your head
like a hair scar for like if i
straighten my hair
um most of the time i'll wrap my hair
going to the actual event because if i
don't my hair will get frizzy
like oh okay and what kind of events are
we talking about
um like you know if i have to go to a
wedding or an actual business event
um like a networking or something like
that just so when i get there my hair
isn't looking
freaky i got a question at 24 years old
what did the women with your kind of
hair do
years ago leaving their house in transit
to the event
um i'm not sure honestly like
mama they didn't work but the thing is
your type of hair is not new that's true
so that's a convenient reason
but there are women who who've had your
kind of hair
and didn't walk out of the house in
bonnets 30 years ago
well i'm sure pretty sure they had like
a hair scarf or something or
braided their hair up or something or
they just had it frizzy
but i don't want my hair frizzy no
because it's an appropriate see
what you're showing is you guys will
find
any reason and i will tell you women did
not just walk around with frizzy hair
[Music]
they weren't allowed to do that you walk
out of the house with that
somebody would have stomped a mud hole
in your butt
so it can't be the reason that the
temperatures aren't different
your hair has existed before the kind of
hair you have has existed before the
events that existed before
and if women were able to get from their
house to the event
then you need to figure out what they
did and do it because it's not okay
i mean well i don't not necessarily i
don't know what the big deal is
if she wears it like just on the way to
it that that would have really bothered
me but i have seen like people
in older pictures and stuff wear scarves
and things i've seen people wear scarves
in the house no like no i've see i've
seen pictures
i know what she's talking about you
usually see a woman with their heads
now we're talking now now we've gone to
the rain
i said different inclement weather is
the reason why i
wear them outside okay um
i know you're going to fight for but now
no well i mean i'm doing i mean i am the
image professional
and i'm 52 and i know that i've seen
decades
yes if you had your if it's raining and
something like that you're going to a
photo shoot with this or that
but you're just talking about going to
an event
see going out of your house with a buy
should not be okay
it should not be okay because and here's
the funny thing what let's just say
let's just say you wanted okay would you
would you like that
let's just say you went you were in a
video that went viral for some reason
would you like being seen worldwide for
the first time in a blindness
probably not then don't do it damn you
cannot control what happens when you
leave your door to where you're going
and everybody has this and in any given
moment
the things that our forefathers and four
mothers told us
when you leave the house you uh you you
you
represent see this is my problem though
i just don't care
like that's why i'm always like i don't
really wear makeup
i'll brush my hair put on a sweatshirt
is that bad am i part of the problem
you could be on this at any given moment
like i would wear a bonnet
because i don't wear bonnets but i would
wear sweats i don't care
you will show would hate for people to
see you for the first time with your
with your head wrapped during the body
whatever it is
that's what they're going to see okay i
have a question for you
really have you ever done ethnic
hair like mine
your dessert have to do i'm not a hair
stylist why is that irrelevant
because if you my hair goes out of me it
touches below my bra strap it's very
long
if my hair if i go outside and it's
humid outside
in houston dallas southern area my hair
is immediately
going to stand up blow out
i would much rather have my hair a
bonnet on for 20
minutes to get to my destination and
take it off rather than have
my hair so how does it so how's your
hair so you mean that
where you go is hermetically sealed so
your hair will blow out if it if it's
exposed
to the atmosphere but it won't blow out
if it's in the event i've lived in
houston
if it's in if it's indoors like an
indoor bank
you're reaching your range you're ready
you're reaching your life
first i could see this like
i could see what she's saying okay no
you're reaching talking about but i hear
what he's saying too like he's saying
how you present yourself to the world
like i get it like how you present
yourself to the world
is like important
i i understand what he's saying okay
first of all i don't have to have done
here
this is the point see what's the point
it doesn't matter how nice y'all sound
this is rebelliousness it's just a
rebellious spirit
it's inappropriate to walk out of your
house in a body
i will say that he did i'm gonna end it
there
because i it's got like a minute left
and i know where he's going
but like honestly he he made the topic
of the show
to make it people that disagree with him
so i don't know how it's rebellious if
you're just giving the opinion
that he asked for um i definitely
understand like what he's saying when he
talks about like
having like the way you present yourself
to the world it's important and your
image is important i totally understand
what he's saying
however i don't think it's like the most
important thing and i don't
think it's that big of a deal if you
want to run to the store to bonnet
like in a place that you don't really
know anyone just my two cents but
let me know in the comments if you agree
with me or you disagree with me
do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and bring that notification bell
for daily videos i will talk to you guys
next time